ich liebe euch das wisst ihr
und ich weiß auch dass eben hier im
video ideen schickt allerdings weiß ich
nicht ob ich mit drang connector so
zufrieden sein werden
dieses spiel haben wir einfach unfassbar
viele von euch meine kommentare
geschrieben unter die letzten videos und
alle meinten so luca du hast ja spinnen
über alles von daher spiel unbedingt
dieses spiel
ich habe keine ahnung worum es in diesem
spiel hier genau geht es ist anscheinend
gesondert uhr simulator wir sehen schon
unten akt 16 sec das sind spinnen ja ich
habe jetzt bildschirm folgenreich und
wieder wolfsburg dopings bei das sind
nicht immer alle sich haben so einen
fetten spinnen sowie ich muss erstmal
hier mich ein bisschen so wie ich will
bei gottes ist nichts hiervon gespielt
ich kann über alles nicht ab in dieser
welt es geht nicht klar warum existiere
diese für yahoo
jumping spyder sallanches family of
cyberspace pcs diversity dies verstehe
überhaupt nix crack besteht hier ich
muss hier drücken und dann holt wie wir
sind also nun diese spinne und können
uns auch drehen und auch das sind feine
also ich jetzt steuert jetzt diese
spinne hier sofern ich das richtig
gesehen habe und ich hab ich noch laufen
ok ich vermisse dich ich will weg ok
auch die latte
das ist doch was seid ihr denn für das
ihr mir sonst spiel schickt ich drehe
mich um mein gott
alter das ist ja das ist ja mein
absoluter albtraum wo man was bist du
für mich aber okay wir sind jetzt also
diese spinne und ich muss mich einfach
mal zusammenreißen
ich laufe hier vorne lange hier passiert
ich kann ich kann stimmt ich meine ich
bin ich bin also ich kann auch an der
decke herlaufen das ist natürlich mega
interessant also ich kann hier rumlaufen
blabla top-down steuerung steht hier
jetzt bin ich wieder auf den boden
zurück luca erinner dich immer wieder
daran dass es einfach nur ein sehr
realistisches spiel ach du meine fresse
alter ich dachte ich hätte mich mal die
ganzen horror spielen die ich schon
gesagt habe krasse erschrocken aber das
hier ist ja echt eine ganz andere liga
ich glaube ich muss tatsächlich kann ich
gott
ok ich kann auch schneller denn ich
glaube da hinten ist offen das heißt ich
rede jetzt einfach mal ganz schnell an
der spinne hier vorbei und bei der doch
kann ich durch das ist auch eine wand wo
muss ich denn dann hin ich weiß nicht ob
ich das irgendwie nicht decke und ja das
ist das arschloch der spinne keine
ahnung was ich jetzt gerade gemacht habe
aber ich glaube ich kann springen wenn
ich jetzt dieses spiel bringt mich auf
180 der golf and grow and major
disasters benzin remains a european
experience now zu beginn alles klar
ich soll mich ein bisschen umschauen
steht hier weit kann nicht rückgängig
mein gott
ich kämpfe ich kenne ich kämpfe gegen
die anderen drei wochen später ich habe
gewonnen
im olymp ist ja vital body fluid blabla
das projekt ist die skills ok blablabla
daheim soll ich machen
das shift okay ich drücke shift okay ich
habe es einmal gemacht das habe ich auch
schon alles gemacht also das habe ich
jetzt auch schon gemacht
ich verstehe nicht was die da von mir
wollen ich muss mir jetzt also irgendwas
zu essen können
hier liegt auf jeden fall etwas zu essen
also dass hier kann nicht fressen konsum
genau jetzt rächt sich dass nämlich rein
hier die gauner umfasst das kann nicht
auffressen genau ich das auch in mich
rein habe mir vor dass auf fast den
ganzen geschwister aber mit das klauen
diese penner die laufen ja auch überall
hin was wollen die denn das wäre ein
absoluter albtraum hier guck dir das mal
an und hier vorne liegt noch was zu
fressen das habe ich mir doch rein ihr
für diese ekelhaften beiden besteht
jetzt liebt hill morning man muss sich
diese beiden sachen gedrückt halten und
hat da jetzt geht die zeit schnell voran
es wird dunkel es regnet
und jetzt wird die nacht und wie lange
dauert die scheiße jetzt noch 2000 jahre
später ja irgendwie hab ich aus dem
affekt die spinne gerade gretchen
genannt also das hier ist jetzt gretchen
ich weiß schon wie luca die krise
kriegen wird im schnitt altra das spiel
das jetzt schon kriege mannheim
herzinfarkt wenn ich diese spinne da
angucken muss und im schnitt muss ja
noch ran zoomen auf die spitze vor lukas
recht ist nicht so schwierig das
zuschneiden es ist auf jeden fall tag 2
angebrochen das heißt ich könnte mich
erst mal was zu frühstücken genau das
ihr euch bereit die ganzen penner die
glauben dass wir erwecken hier liegt
noch was zu essen das kann ich mir noch
eben reinhauen
aber ich weiß noch nicht genau was meine
nächste challenge sein wird einem die
sonne geht auf sehen wir gerade genau
ich mir dass wir noch rein und wo ist
die sonne sonne sonne
wo ist diese ekelhaften beider es gibt
bei diesem spiel auf jeden fall
verschiedene möglichkeiten das zu
spielen und das was ich gerade mache ist
so die der standard weg also der
karrieremodus so ein bisschen
also ich muss das leben einer spinne von
kleinauf bis zum tod durch leben
es gibt aber noch irgendwas da kann man
sich selbst die natur bauen eine welt
bauen und alles entdecken also das spiel
das heute wirklich eigentlich einen
natur simulator in dem man ja die natur
simuliert also mein enkel hat sich auf
jeden fall ein bisschen abgelegt schon
wieder
hier ist vorn allerdings auch die ganze
zeit neues fressen also ich glaube ich
muss wirklich einfach fressen und
dadurch wachse ich weil ich glaube meine
spinne ist schon ein bisschen größer
geworden
oder ich fress jetzt einfach mal 2000
jahre lang alles was sie irgendwie in
diesem test rumliegt 2000 jahre später
ich kann nichts mehr machen ich muss
wege drückt halten und dann
schlüpfe ich aus meiner
haut raus und ich bin deutscher ich bin
the world and you'll be big enough to
run train audi trios lieblings sind
place to gain experience okay blablabla
also ich muss jetzt noch meine
geschwister besiegen
in diesem spiel kampf und danach kann
ich anscheinend aus dem nest raus albums
hier nochmals eine leichte attacke dann
hier noch mal und dann mache ich hier
noch mal eine kleine attacke hier
nochmal eine fette also die dreikämpfe
habe ich gewonnen
das heißt ich könnte mir jetzt hier ist
nur noch ein bisschen was zu fressen
dann müssten wir allerdings gleich
eigentlich auch schon jeden moment groß
genug sein um wirklich aus dieser welt
rauszukommen bezwingen steven ist und so
richtig in die kamera wie ekelhaft das
aussieht guck dir das mal an was das
erwarte ich nun live stage uwe press
trade
okay das ist jetzt unsere dritte live
stage dann glaube ich das heißt ich
finde es sehr hart kraft ich weiß nicht
wieso ich bin nochmals größer geworden
express travelers fast ein paar sekunden
später aber unser nächstes offen
gegangen das heißt wir können jetzt hier
in die große weite welt raus krabbeln
und sehen schon da
das hier ist unser kader ist dass das
arschloch von unserer mama guck mal da
klebt sogar ein geschwisterkind von mir
drauf rein war mit flower bett liest
vorfahren ezb 808 wir sind nur aufgaben
kleinen blatt
dann sind wir ein richtig kleiner knirps
oh mein gott ich habe mich in ein könig
der löwen wo sind wir hier so steht de
ist kein königreich gehört die erwartete
offizielle leute die bibel
allerdings würde ich sagen dass wir den
rest von dieser wunderschönen natur hier
das nächste mal in der nächsten episode
erkunden werden
ich hatte eigentlich gedacht dass das
ganze noch ein kleines gastspiel ist
weil das immer nur drei euro kostet aber
es scheint anscheinend wirklich ein
bisschen komplexer zu sein wenn ihr
wollt darauf hat dass ich hier vorn
eventuell noch einen zweiten teil hohen
aber dann würde ich mich auf jeden fall
durchringen mit meiner spende probiert
das ganze spiel nochmal zu spielen
die tage hier auf meinem kanal hass auf
jeden fall gern einen daumen hoch unter
dem video david der bock drauf habt
abonniert zudem einen kanal dann
verpasste das video dann nicht und ja
ich werde das spiel jetzt direkt pendelt
[Musik]